Trascrizione: Martina Cifani
Revisore: Piero Cavallo
Sono a Kunduz.
È notte fonda quando mi sveglia.
Mi devo essere appisolato
sul pavimento della camerata.
Ancora con il giubbetto antiproiettile.
Lui urla cose incomprensibili,
con gli occhi iniettati di sangue.
O forse sono rossi di lacrime.
Dice: “Dobbiamo andare”.
In qualche modo capisco che
un suo compagno è stato ucciso.
E deve tornare in città, al funerale.
E io devo andare con lui.
Sono sotto la sua responsabilità.
Ma nessuno si muove di notte
su queste strade, sono piene di mine.
I talebani attaccano
i convogli dell’esercito.
Ma non c’è verso di farlo ragionare.
Usciamo in fila fra i muri di difesa.
Troppo buio per fotografare.
I militari tentano un fuoco di copertura.
Cioè sparano a caso nella notte
mentre saliamo sul mezzo blindato.
E poi la notte.
Quello che resta della strada
è una serie di buche,
fatte dalle mine, piazzate dai talebani,
intramezzate da un breve tratto d’asfalto.
Non procediamo tanto velocemente, anche
se l’impressione è quella della velocità.
So che dobbiamo solo arrivare al prossimo
avamposto a pochi chilometri.
Sono dieci minuti, venti.
Sembra un’eternità.
I fari aprono un varco
nell’oscurità densa.
Nessuno parla.
Tutti sono all'erta.
Tutti soli.
Con la propria paura.
E poi arriviamo.
Non è successo niente.
Lui continua verso la città e mi lascia
in questa postazione, nelle retrovie.
Qualcuno mi trova una branda vicino alla
stufa e mi riaddormento di sasso.
Sono a New York.
Sono arrivato presto.
Non sono abituato a vestirmi così formale.
Esco dalla metropolitana
e la scena è imponente.
I palazzi, le insegne luminose,
la gente di fretta che mi urta.
E Times Square.
Mi rifugio in uno Starbucks.
Il caffè non è granché ed è costoso.
Tutto vetro attorno.
Dal mio tavolo vedo la strada
e fin dentro al palazzo di fronte.
I giovani seduti agli altri tavoli
sembrano sicuri di sé.
Come se sapessero dove andare
e avessero fretta di arrivarci.
Davanti a me, sul tavolo,
il mio portfolio.
Tutte le decisioni
che ho preso nella mia vita,
condensate in 30 foto.
Mi avvio verso l'entrata del giornale.
Soffitti altissimi, vetrate, marmo.
Il signore alla scrivania
si mette al telefono.
E cerca di dire il mio nome correttamente.
Non ci riesce, ma mi fa entrare comunque.
Mi fa un pass
con cui accedo agli ascensori.
Devono essere almeno sei
e non tutti vanno nel posto giusto.
Non ricordo quanti piani sono. Dodici?
Ad ogni modo dura un’infinità.
Meno male che non c’è nessuno
con me in questa scatola di metallo.
Sono agitato.
Non avrò mica già l'alone?
Un minuto? 40 secondi?
Interminabili.
E poi arrivo.
Alice esce a prendermi, è sorridente.
Comincia il nostro meeting.
Ora, se mi chiedete quando sento
la paura più spesso,
non c’è dubbio che mi succeda quando sono
dietro la macchina fotografica.
È la paura di fare delle foto mediocri.
Io ho avuto una vita bella,
tranquilla, senza traumi.
Vengo da un paese qua vicino.
Le paure di cui ho fatto esperienza
sono i piccoli timori della crescita,
la socialità, gli esami a scuola.
E poi è arrivata la fotografia.
Amo la fotografia.
Ma allo stesso tempo mi terrorizza
perché non c’è una seconda possibilità.
Immagina una reazione a quello
che c’è in quel momento davanti a me.
E niente si ripete.
La paura è un sentimento orrendo.
Non posso fare altro
che volere che smetta.
Ma non è tutto uguale.
Alle volte è irrazionale
o lavora con un suo tempismo peculiare.
È più forte prima di affrontare
una situazione.
Mentre quando lo affronto,
come ora,
l’interminabile monologo dei pensieri
nella mia testa s’interrompe.
E sono all’erta.
Le priorità sono chiare, impellenti.
E poi posso avere paura
di ferire il mio corpo
o di ferire il mio senso di identità.
E forse è quest’ultima
la mia paura peggiore.
Anche in una zona di guerra.
La mia paura più grande è sempre stata
quella di fare delle foto mediocri.
E con il tempo mi sono reso conto che
è del mio ego che mi preoccupa di più.
Le foto mediocri mettono in discussione
la mia identità, quella di fotografo.
E se faccio delle foto mediocri,
il fatto stesso di essere in quel luogo
perde di senso.
Alle volte ci sono delle cose di me
di cui non piace parlare,
mi infastidiscono,
se si toccano certi argomenti.
Sono degli elementi della mia personalità
che in qualche modo voglio solo evitare.
Ma poi penso che se ho
questa reazione emotiva,
se ho paura di affrontare queste cose,
è perché devono essere importanti per me.
Quindi invece di evitarle,
forse sono proprio queste le cose
che dovrei affrontare se voglio crescere.
Quindi la paura, forse,
può aiutarmi a capire quali sono
le cose che mi stanno più a cuore.
Ogni singola volta che ho deciso
di affrontare una situazione
che mi faceva paura,
ho imparato qualcosa.
E non sto ovviamente parlando
di pericolo fisico.
Prima di tutto,
ho sentito la gratificazione istantanea
di averlo fatto.
Perché in genere poi non succede nulla.
E poi c’è il sollievo, la gioia di aver
aperto la porta a nuove possibilità.
È un senso di legittimazione che
mi spinge ad andare avanti,
a lavorare più intensamente.
La paura, come il dolore,
sarà sempre parte della nostra vita.
Ci si presenterà in diverse forme,
alle volte in modo inaspettato.
Ad esempio, per me
anche in una zona di guerra
il timore più grande è sempre stato
quello di fare delle foto mediocri.
E quindi,
per diventare una persona migliore,
è necessario guardare in faccia
le nostre paure, i nostri demoni.
È necessario accettare,
superare i fallimenti.
O la paura dei fallimenti.
Grazie.
(Applausi)